One of the reasons for the current
reemergence of frozen sniffed,
so to speak,
is that sniffed potentially a together
with international companies could,
as I said,
this place Gazprom troll.
So I think just focusing on gas from.
It's not really,
it's not really entirely accurate.
I think you should look at when we're
talking about this,
these issues,
we need to look at what the independent
producers can do and can deliver.
And again,
which volumes we're talking about how
much,
how much,
uh,
you know,
for us at the moment,
I think the key dilemmas to retain his
role in,
in European markets potentially maybe
increase it slightly.